tonight on Hotel Hell imagine if a
teenage boy designed a hotel it would
look like a
Ferrari that's a lot of red there'd be a
chocolate pizza on the menu it's like
someone's wiped their with my dough and
there'd be hot waitresses with super
short skirts well this is the keing
hotel looks like a nightclub out there
with those ropes it might seem like a
teenager's dream but it's actually the
Twisted vision of a grown man and for
the staff who work here I'm at the end
of my room I have my days number here
it's a living hell Jesus Christ call 911
urgently
San Diego California is one of the top
five vacation destinations in the US and
is home to the keing hotel which lies in
the heart of the city's buzzing Gas Lamp
quarter want to say the desk this is
Christ how may you be of
service the hotel is the brain chart of
local property developer Eddie Kane
everything about the place is just the
way he likes it the keing was my vision
I was at the Ferrari dealer looking at
cars and it kind of just hit me why not
have the Ferrari of hotels
but this 35 room Boutique Hotel is far
from living up to guest
expectations oh my gosh Eddie pitches
this as the Ferrari of hotels but it
feels like a hospital sterile almost
this is all style and no substance I
feel like it's a jail like I don't want
to take my shoes off ever this is uh not
exactly
luxury Eddie hard a sports car design
company and sank Millions into the
interior design but he spent peanuts on
things the hotel really needs
let's not use this machine for the
sheets because it has rust in the back
making life a misery for his guests and
his staff I have zero resources pretty
much everything there is to do here I do
it how glamorous is this it's a hell
operations here to be
honest Eddie's constantly adding ideas
he's seen elsewhere but that's hurting
the hotel and the restaurant I believe
our menu is [__] joke it's like four
pages long which are all favorites of
vies but we're not feing a [__]
million different edes we're feeding
different
people is
hor at the end of the day I am the owner
right if there's something I want in the
menu Chef's going to do it yeah I think
I piss them
up Eddie will come in and say I want a
chicken parm slider on the menu I had
one in New York and I say yes I have
stopped being proud of my
food the hotel is millions of dollars in
debt and struggling to fill the rooms so
I have my work cut out for me if I'm
going to get this place back on track
we're losing a lot of money it's a
nightmare but you should be able to
handle that Eddie he knows he's losing
money I just don't think he knows how to
fix it I don't have any hope that things
will get better if anything Works around
here it's because of pure dumb
[Music]
luck there it is the keting wow looks
nice on the outside
Beautiful Jesus is that a dog outside
hello how are you good how are you is
that a model dog or is he real no she's
real what's her name smudge smudge my
God she's
ugly looks like a nightclub out there
with those ropes how are we hello how
are you good to see you there's a lot of
red wow I'm Christos Christos good to
see you what did you do here lifestyle
con down here at the front desk you
going to be advising me for my life or
you going to be dinner reservations so
you organize everything anything you
need oh now somebody likes red is that
smudged likes red or no it's both the
designer and the owner wow wow wow enjoy
your stst what floor we on we're on the
second floor second floor please perfect
thank
you right here I like to always stop at
the car each floor has a different model
car who's obsessed with the super cars
who is that the owner everybody so right
here this is your
room wow yes it's so empty more like a
Gage in the guest room and how much is
this a night
$759
$759 wow that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there that is actually
the jacuzzi tub in the middle of the
lounge it is in the middle of the lounge
wow when they designed the rooms they
took away all the interior walls but
without sounding stupid these are car
designers correct they are car designers
now they're putting jacuzzi in the
middle of sweet last time I checked a
living room was for sitting in not
taking a bath
how much do these things cost the
jacuzzi tub itself is about $220,000 you
don't take Bing cars Jesus this is crazy
but who wanted all these specially
designed that is the OWN are that's
Eddie that's Eddie yes this is
crazy [__] the sports car inspired
Furniture looks cheap and isn't even
functional it's different than anything
else um different from a nice hotel room
oh I don't know about that who in Earth
want to sit here and sort of watch the
television and watch the television
CL it works
though the sheets how can they all so
wrinkled when I haven't even slept in
there why is that we do them in house
when you say we what do you mean you
don't do laundry lifestyle means
everything your mouthwash it's like gas
sockets all broken and smashed down
there someone's left their dirty ones
there the plastic plants that's
outrageous $800 oh my gosh Gordon
doesn't like anything about the hotel
damnn it anything else if I have any
lifestyle needs I'll call thank you of
course so far I'm not impressed with a
keating's pretentious and uncomfortable
design but maybe it can redeem itself
with the one thing every luxury hotel
should have impeccable room service I'm
starving on on the desk this is Christos
how many hi Christ this Gordon what's a
little bit bizarre for me is that I'm
ordering room service at the front desk
is it there's no direct line down to the
kitchen there is no direct line down to
the kitchen the communication
departments isn't there really there so
we um take care of everything make sure
it it happens listen I'm starving um
I'll have a tomato soup please and then
pizza and barbecue chicken I'm
fascinated to see the chicken parmesan
sliders I'll have one of those as soon
as I can brilliant byebye thank you
bye hello hello how are
you thank you my pleasure well is this
how it's normally served yes in a tiger
box yes you pay $800 a night to stay
here and you got to eat your food out of
boxes and plastic
containers are we short the soup cuz
it's not even half full that's how they
serve it that's how that that much yes
it's one cup it's like a retirement home
is that luxury you think no not at all
what would you rather
do sip that out of a cup of course jeez
we we barely got half a cup um anyway
I'm going to dig in if there's anything
else I can do for you just go ahead and
let us
okay darling I'm
sorry you can say that now it's finished
thank you my
pleasure a chicken parmesan
slider that's
Dreadful ah [__] me now I know why they
got the boxes it's a takeway puke
box Pizza unappetizing in a box
especially when you're spending $800 a
night this place is obsessed with design
but serves room service in plastic
containers no wonder they can't fill the
rules that is not my idea of lock sh let
me tell you that's
embarrassing
[Music]
wow how can this place call itself a
luxury hotel I need to get some answers
from Eddie the keting owner and
Visionary hey how are you he how are you
good to see you this place has been your
baby in many ways and I'm dying to find
out the vision the insight and to why
give us a little tour I bought the
building back in 200000 I was around 6
million did you go to hotel school no
you've never run a business before not a
hotel business now wow so I was actually
at the Ferrari dealer looking at cars
and stuff and it kind of hit me why not
the Ferrari of hotels I'm more concerned
what you were smoking at the time than
what you were
thinking why would you take one of the
most highs speec cars anywhere in the
world and turn it into a hotel
I don't know where he's coming from but
it does piss me off I designed the keing
to be the perfect hotel for me not for
him where should I start the floor it's
all scuffed and marked when you have a
resin floor it needs to be updated I
mean everything's just marked to hell it
feels cheap um the sheets you can't call
yourself a luxury hotel if you don't
have beautifully pressed sheets okay
what's the idea behind sitting here so
when you have guests you know we can sit
down and talk and but where's the sofa
where's the table where's the fun
you know what hurtt the most I got soup
served in a plastic Bowl but there's a
chicken parmesan slider that tasted like
it was cooked 3 days ago who in the [__]
would put a chicken parmesan slider
together there's things that don't go in
sliders and chicken Palm is one of them
that was my idea but you're laughing as
if it's funny and you think because you
own the place you can put that in a roll
and sell it I don't know what he's
talking about this place is not bad so I
think Gordon's comments were complete
[__] your trying to convince me this
is your idea of luxury I don't know what
to say when was the last time you stayed
in the hotel it's been a while you
cannot stand there and tell me that
there's nothing wrong with this place
when you don't even stay in
it you bought a building that was your
dream but it doesn't feel like a dream
experience to a guest nowhere [__]
near
[Music]
it I'm at the keting hotel in San Diego
and I've just met Eddie the owner who's
completely oblivious to the fact that
his Supercar inspired hotel is seriously
underperforming you're the owner and you
bought a building that was your dream
but it doesn't feel like a dream
experience to a guest nowhere [__]
near
it I desperately want to help you only
if you start identifying the problems
okay could you uh send that young lady
up to clear that dog [__] out of there
please
Jesus trust me Eddie is not used to
honesty like that right now he looks
like a baby that's just had his lollipop
stolen how are you who is this guy first
thing he does he lays right into me the
room service was terrible welcome to my
world he opened the bed up and the
sheets were all like wrinkled and most
hotels have those giant iron in things
that the sheets go through there we
don't have that I tell Eddie the
problems that we have but it may be
sometimes you tell people something and
it goes one side to another I was in
shock maybe Gordon will get him to wake
up I even know what to say that was very
[Music]
embarrassing after my meeting with Eddie
I'm ready to see how this so-called
luxury hotel runs on a normal night hi
there how are you guys great how are you
are you a luxury lifestyle concer no I
am actually Sandra I'm the GM of the
hotel the general manager oh we met how
long you been here I've been here for 6
years okay wow so you're here from the
beginning mhm wow wow wow wow I got a
love to tell you you got a lot to tell
me yeah I bet she does because the
keying seems to have more complaints
than guests our room is not very clean
there's a hair in the cheets as well we
turned down our bed and there's what
appears to be a bunch of sand a sand
what do you think of the red it's like a
brothel you've been in a brothel I
haven't just what I've heard okay wow I
can confirm it is like a rle is
it cheese plate let me check on that
right now we've been waiting for 45
minutes you know if it's not up in 10
minutes just cancel it cuz we'll go to
dinner okay okay how can they make a
guest wait so long for something that's
not even cooked the system for room
service here is clearly not working
taking the orders at the front desk then
passing them to the kitchen is madness
I've never seen anything like this
before let's go through the kitchen
together okay weirdly the hotel's
restaurant the MC is in a separate
building around the corner can you
believe that they're waiting for 45
minutes for cheeseboard I can't believe
it but I'm not surprised she looked
pretty pissed huh she did look pretty
pissed they sounded pissed the three
times they called as well wow what is it
is it a cheeseboard yes uh where's the
[__] cheese is that it that is it how
much is that $6.99 I believe you're
kidding me I can guarantee someone's
going to complain about that hello how
are you Gordon how are you my name is
Aon manager you're the manager nice to
see nice to meet you g um you're the
manager of the restaurant yes sir that
chees portion there barely two little
slithers of cheese they waited 45
minutes forks and it's like no one gives
a [__] oh I definitely do now that
you've told me this is the first time
that I've heard of it why would they
wait 45 minutes for something that's
already I I think the process
unfortunately is a little bit slow here
I think getting up the stairs is a
little bit of a challenge why don't you
take the call in the kitchen oh in the
kitchen itself we can take that call
it's definitely an option but we've
always what do you think that's faster I
think as the hotel takes it it's just as
fast as so even though the customers are
unhappy with the weight that they've had
to endure you don't want to do anything
for them I didn't know how long the
customer is waiting until just
now wow okay manager not
me Aaron the restaurant manager isn't
taking any
responsibility if he worked for me he'd
be long gone how [__] weird how' you
rate him out of 10 can we go into
negatives Aaron is the king of excuses
as far as being able to kind of weasel
his way out of things but I'm not in
charge of firing
him how we doing over here guys no
wonder the hotel is half empty they
can't even get the Basics like room
service and laundry ride maybe Sandra
the GM can tell me what the hell is
going on here right we have a chance to
catch up thank you so all these issues
with the laundry where's the laundry
done let me show you
please oh here we are so this is the
laundry room well bloody hell you have
got your work cut out these are domestic
I know these wash machines are designed
for small families not a 35- bedroom
hotel wow no wonder they struggle your
life St coner come in here throughout
their day to do laundry and attend the
front desk and take room service orders
we all do I mean this is crazy it is
insane it is insane I don't know how we
do it sometimes who presses the sheets
we don't we don't have equipment so you
don't press
them can I show you where we are in the
pillowcases absolutely God there
somewhere else you seem to know all
these problems and you're the general
manager but if there's one person who
can stop this it's you if the owner well
yes I can quit I can leave to another
hotel and go where everything is much
better it is hell to run this place
you're a general manager mhm yet you're
managing nothing I spoke to the owner I
said this has to change what's going on
Gordon is totally right with what he's
saying but is Eddie being so involved in
everything that's the problem I have
conversations with the owner about what
works and what doesn't work in the
restaurant no matter how many times I
say you know what we should not have a
book as a menu Eddie comes up with
whatever he wants but no one's taken
responsibility I pull back my duvet and
the Sheets Were
shocking $800 a night to stay in
something pretty mediocre you should be
ashamed I am ashamed I am ashamed I got
to get out of here let me get down to
the
restaurant
Jesus coming up I've never seen anything
so [__] unappetizing things at the
keting go from bad to worse I wouldn't
serve any of our dishes to my dog you
okay and one of the staff reaches his
Breaking Point call 911 please quickly
[Music]
urgently for a so-called luxury hotel
the keting has been a major
disappointment it's like gas the owner's
misguided Vision you're trying to
convince me this is your idea of luxury
it's taking its toll on the staff it is
hell to run this place hopefully the
food in the hotel's restaurant is better
than it was in my room all how are you
do table of one
please o can you me hey good evening how
are you I'm very well and yourself very
well thank you and sorry wel to the mer
my name is David David so what did you
do I am actually the restaurant manager
here I thought I just met the restaurant
manager the little man I'm the other
restaurant
manager and the food how would you RIT
the food out of 10 six six I wouldn't
serve any of our dishes to my dog Chef
Brian's kind of given up so much has
been taken out of Brian's Hands by Eddie
that I don't think that he has the
passion in the drive to be that great
anymore starting off with chicken under
a break what does that actually mean it
means it's drier than a
bone amazing even the manager thinks the
food's terrible here and he's not
embarrassed to tell me and then the
katti katabi yeah here we go with
chicken s Tomatoes mushrooms you like
that one no [__] really uh I'm still
going to try it so for desserts I'll
have to go for the chocolate pig um it's
a 10 in uh dessert pizza chocolate
strawberries
bacon how can I resist that thank you
very much indeed thank you the table I'm
ringing right now just bring it as it
comes okay everything's Under
Fire that's for all right what do we
have here this is the brick chicken $21
$21 brick chicken yeah it looks like
someone's just shat a
brick
[Applause]
it's so dry yeah I mean really dry
that's actually better than usual really
yeah chicken under a brick is where it
should have stayed because it should
have never come out of the
kitchen wow pardon my reaching okay this
is the kabat tapian chicken
okay Bland chicken's dry way too much
Rosemary and just it's
[__]
at least I've save room for dessert what
you have here is the chocolate
pig white and dark chocolate
strawberries bacon it's like we've had a
crisis with a toilet paper Department
someone's wiped their ass with my
dough I mean it's just I've never seen
anything so [__] unappetizing as a
dessert in all my life
absolutely bacon and chocolate pizza om
FG
you see him SP it up yeah he didn't like
any of it not one thing [__]
me is the chef off tonight no he's in
the back he's in the back is he cooking
or no so he's here but he's not
cooking I would uh really like to meet
the uh executive
chef
Chef Brian ruford Gordon Ramsey how are
you let's go somewhere out the L show
I'm lost for words I just you know I
don't know I didn't know where to start
I'm why wouldn't you cook for me why
wouldn't you do that it's not a question
of me not cooking for you it's do you
want to see what we're doing here and
improv because I want this to improve
you've been here for how long 5 years 5
years but you've been cooking for 30
years 33 years 33 years
I didn't see you on the line I didn't
see you taste anything you I didn't even
see you inspire anybody this position is
killing me in my soul I've just been
doing everything that Eddie wanted we
have two large menu for the amount of
business we do if I have 120 items on
the menu and we do 50 people a night how
much of this am I able to prep on a
regular basis to have quality but you're
the executive chef on the menu yes I am
how can you let let that food go out
with your name above it um you can't
just give up and almost you know Abandon
Ship before it's sunk I'm at the end of
my world you're toast I'm tired but
you're you're you're an experienced
guy you
okay look at me look at me he standing
you
okay are you on medication yeah excuse
me can you get me some uh water please
quickly can you get me a chair
please a
chair Jesus Christ call 911 please
quickly 911 Jesus come here Jesus Christ
urgently what happened chef's on the
floor [__] can I have some you okay call
911 Jesus Christ Chef just fell
collapsed can I have some water please
and a cold cloth
urgently just try to stay alone
look at me look at me
Brian can you get me a chair please a
chair Jesus Christ call 911 please
quickly 911 Jesus come here Jesus Christ
chef's on the floor Jesus Christ Chef
just felt collapsed just try and stay
alert and drink some
water no job is worth it this let me
tell
[Music]
you I was with the gentleman where we
just standing talking unfortunately he
just claps and banged his head on the
back
air I am really pissed off at Gordon
he's stressing everybody out everyone
seems to be at their boiling point has
he been stressed out for long I mean
this put a lot of stress on all of us
but me being here yeah but do not dare
[__] go anywhere near that I put him
in that ambulance got it let me tell you
something 150 items on a [__] menu
the size of a [__] shoe box can send
that man to an early grave let me tell
you it's like he's a dead man walking
yeah and what he tried to tell me in a
5minute conversation is that you've
overburdened him cuz he does whatever
you want you pay salary but you're not
behind that line you have no catering
experience you haven't spent a day in a
kitchen I've never seen anything so
fragmented okay it's like you're a
little magpie a little spoiled [__]
macpie that's going around picking up
little bits of glitter and running back
and getting your army to expedite it for
you all that matters right now is that
that guy wakes up tomor feeling better
enough is enough for one day yeah thank
you good
night for me the most important thing is
that he's okay but that guy has the
world on his shoulders and tonight
proved
that what a day yesterday the good news
is that Brian's out of hospital and they
said it was dehydration and anxiety so
I'm going to shoot over to his house
keep the cameras outside and hopefully
have a chat with
him how are you sir come on in I'm so
glad to see you you know that I'm
telling you how are you feeling I'm
feeling well we've got immense troubles
at BO you cannot continue driving
yourself into the ground like that Eddie
takes advantage of my good nature do you
feel well enough to come back to the
restaurant today yeah good let's get you
back in there and trust me this time
it's on your terms not Edie's definitely
good to see
you the restaurant is the beating heart
of any good hotel Hotel so the keing has
no chance without Chef Brian thankfully
just a couple of hours after I saw him
Brian is back at the hotel after going
to the hospital I believe that Gordon is
totally in my corner saying get back in
there get it you you got this guy than
now it's time to get the whole staff
together to figure out how to get this
hotel back on track thank you all for
meeting me am I happy to see you or what
how are you feeling more importantly I
am feeling very good brilliant welcome
back thank you very
let's get everything out on the table
cuz Life's too short to Festa I'm here
to
help and I just want to hear it from you
guys what's wrong with the
keting the resources is the resources I
tell Eddie all the time Eddie I can do
my job your front reception desk should
not be doing laundry let me tell you
that the big concern I have is the room
service how on Earth do we get ourselves
in that mess as a food and beverage
manager yeah tell me why it's going via
the reception it's determined by you
know Eddie oh my God don't give me
that you're not the owner of the place I
tell you what I want and you guys need
to implement
it why is the menu so big because Eddie
comes up with ideas I Eddie sees things
Eddie has a lot of friends that come in
that would like to see more items on the
menu if I go see something I like for
somewhere else I tell you guys to
implement it but you're not a chef he is
and he needs his identity and he needs
his voice I do know Brian doesn't like
to say no to
me you have a general manager you have a
head chef executive chef you have a
front desk man you shouldn't get
involved and I give them ideas you know
cuz I have a vision here and I give them
the ideas no I take criticism
no I cannot work with you if you're like
this we have the key players the there's
one little problem we have and
unfortunately it's it's you and this
this
point after last night's dramatic turn
of events Look At Me Jesus Christ the St
K have finally found the courage to
confront Eddie the owner now there's one
question I have to ask tell me who's the
most important person at the keting who
is
it Eddie bran yeah the most important
person at the keting Sandra who is it I
I got to say it's
Eddie I mean I believe it would be Eddie
Eddie SRA no
no the most important person at the
keing is the
guest and I think it's all been
forgotten
about and it's more about keeping you
Eddie
happy we have to focus on the
guest I'm here to put this place right
understand
that Eddie and Sandra just come with me
if Eddie won't listen to me and he won't
listen to his staff maybe he'll listen
to the people who could pay the bills
Around Here Eddie up until now this
hotel has always been about you your
dream your vision now it's about the
guest want me to meet some very
important people I'm just really worried
right now I have no idea what Gordon has
in the room hello how are you I see our
guests that have been staying at the
keing over the last 24 to 48 hours oh no
when I see all those guests there I want
to run right now I wanted to give you a
unique opportunity to hear some very and
I mean very valuable feedback I've also
stayed here um and I am frustrated but
I'm here to get this place back on the
map give you a little insight please
what do you think of this luxury
hotel Madam or you I walked into the
room and it smelled horrible there was
no rust in the jacuzzi no
water some of the features in the room
were just lower quality like the plastic
looked a little bit cheap and old so
doesn't feel comfortable M please I just
feel like this place was designed kind
of form over function it was just kind
of weird where is one supposed to sit
and eat breakfast in their room my
husband had to stand up this morning to
have his breakfast while I took the only
chair and sat at the desk I'm sorry our
our room service was um we ordered a
couple of the small pizzas and they
essentially looked like microwave pizzas
and then the order was wrong so we
called the correct they eventually you
know brought up what we actually ordered
and then in the morning they charged us
for both wow I'm sorry anybody else
there was some really high-end stuff and
then at the same time there was just
simple amenities that were skipped are
you saying there's better at the same
price out
there yeah Eddie your baby your vision
um on the back of that feedback no I
appreciate the
feedback I have one question for you all
who would return here let's do a show of
hands who would come back to the
keying wow not one
person Gordon's comment about it's not
what I want it's what the guests want
wow I'm starting to realize that some of
the things he's saying actually are
true I really apologize and I am looking
forward to having you guys in the future
I can tell you we'll have a different
experience Eddie and Sandra you know I'm
not trying to embarrass you but this is
for me critical feedback and it's only
going to get
better the feedback from the customers
was good I'm realizing there's more
issues than I thought we had and just
being here over the past couple days I'm
seeing what they are I think we can
definitely fix them and streamline them
so the place works a lot more
efficiently and all the guests are happy
thank you I appreciate
it Eddie is starting to see how much
things have to change for this place to
succeed but for the hotel to have a
Fighting Chance of turning a profit I've
got to find a way to reignite Chef
Brian's Love of Cooking let's show the
gang what we can do yeah I don't have
much passion here anymore I'm hoping
that that that Gordon being here will
nurse it back and right first was the
roasted beet and B salad they've just
been seasoned with a little touch of
salt pepper and then finished in a
little hazelnut vinegar scops I like
serving scallops with a nice sear so
Touch of salt pepper little bit of
vinegar and I've just made it sort of
citrusy sorry I love it when you get
excited like that see that energy coming
back I absolutely love it I just have a
little taste
are you okay
Brian you're killing me there's two
things on the plates got the scops and
the onion P when I'm on the line with
Gordon the energy level just pops up and
now I'm you know I'm standing a little
taller and it's exciting nice happy yeah
good so nice to see you smiling you know
that Gordon kind of unlocked the chains
that I had allowed to be put on I'm with
you every step of the way but you need a
voice in here and your voice is on that
plate let it
scream I love Eddie but I have to be
able to just say this is not going to
work this is not to the benefit of the
hotel the guests the restaurant or
anything you can do it and I know you
can do it I needed this
to remember what I used to do and that
that there's no limit to what I can do
in the
future Brian and Eddie are both making
great strides and tonight my design team
will move in and try to get this hotel
out of the pits but first there's
something I've just got to try I've got
a 25 Grand bath so I might as well use
it
that does not fa and sound like a 25 CR
bath let me tell
you someone's been ripped off right to
please it's been a challenging week at
the keting hotel a place that was all
style and no substance but its owner
Eddie has finally turned a corner good
morning morning how are we good
excellent it's time to show him and his
staff how my design team have
transformed the keting into a place
people will actually want to stay okay
good let's be honest the keting is a
hotel with huge potential right yes but
you need to focus your attention and
energy to the guests that are staying
here yeah come with me let me show you
the keting let's go come in
welcome wow come in that is great oh my
God it's all opened
up wow there's no more dominant red re
read carefully all those wonderful
configurations of your hands welcome to
the
KY it's just so beautiful isn't it it's
just such an emotional experience you
all have a hand in helping the guest
feel welcome it's amazing you
disappointed the red is gone no no no
it's a brand new warm inviting entrance
to a hotel ready to see more yeah nice
nice nice
come into my
Suite oh my god wow so much nice oh wow
God oh my God oh my
God oh my
God I am definitely blown way wow wow oh
my God welcome to what I think is a
sophisticated comfortable modern suweet
yeah let's start off with that Jacuzzi
if guess would like to take a bath pull
the curtains they have a choice that's
how you embody luxury the sofas you can
sit down you can watch TV 3 m away from
the screen Brian you going quiet on me
again jeez we thought we were sleek and
cool and now it's beautiful it feels
welcoming come through the bedroom
please I really like the concept of the
Mover Suite now it screams the guests
you get stuck in a perspective
sometimes and you need to take a step
back and have someone you know come in
and show you and I think that's what
Gordon has done it's amazing now
something really important I've
organized a free trial period from a
local linen company use it to your
advantage that means the front desk team
doesn't need to waste time doing laundry
you got more time to focus on the
guest and Sandra you are a GM you're not
a laundry assistant the Lifest are
concered we don't have to worry about
laundry so I am happy there's more let's
go right excited yes come through we
have refreshed the menu okay oh my God
breakfast pizza I've worked with Chef
Brian to devise a short new menu that
will play to his strengths First
Impressions visually it's very Briant
the presentation's amazing and the good
news is 2third of the menu is gone Chef
what do you think I think that this
allows me to speak to the guest and
aarin I want you as the food and
beverage manager to take responsibility
of room service own it and no plastic
containers I I think now we have the
proper execution the proper
understanding of the menu with limited
smaller items we definitely can execute
it a lot quicker and now I feel a lot
more comfortable and that for me is
great news cuz it means the front desk
is no longer looking after room service
or do laundry they can concentrate on
looking after the guests yes there's one
more change we need to do you've been
wearing a red chef jacket for far too
long you deserve a white one let me tell
you put that on thank you enjoy it I
certainly will I'm feeling great I'm no
longer Eddie's Chef in the red jacket
I'm the chef of the Merc beastro in
white it's not Eddie's favorite color
but it is a proper chef jacket you
perform like one you deserve it make it
yours thank you Gordon well
done this is the kind of energy you want
to see every day so you know what as
long as they're doing their jobs I have
no problem with them saying no to me
anymore big night tonight it's going to
be a packed restaurant you've got to
remember you are all team keing I know
you can do it oh absolutely
absolutely guests are arriving for the
relaunch of the keing hotel are you and
the first impressions are very positive
this is really nice you like it oh yeah
oh this is beautiful at long last the
front desk can focus on welcoming guests
how are you welcome I'm Cindy pleasure
to meet you and the hotel's new white
Lobby is a great Improvement at this all
red and before it looked like a bus
station now it looks like a hotel it
looks much more inviting at the
restaurant Aaron is finally stepping up
follow right and taking a new Hands-On
approach to room service and not a
plastic container in
[Music]
sight Mr Hanks right excellent we got
room service over here for you
the simplified menu has brought Brian
back to life I want the most gorgeous
plates in the world coming up in this
window that's good news for the diners
so beautiful it's very tender it's like
I don't even need this knife this is a
joint where you don't need ketchup it's
perfectly seasoned and for the future of
Eddie and the keting hotel keep it going
that's amazing oh my gosh look how T
it's
perfect if I had one thing to say to
Gordon right now is just thanks
all right ladies and gentlemen it's our
last ticket out I've been really lost
here and you've woken me up great job
new day new day and reminded me of who I
am this place was all about Eddie's
dream of what a hotel should be like but
he forgot the most important person the
guest I'm just hoping that Eddie can
trust his staff and let them work as a
team because this is a place I'd love to
come back
to
okay right Sandra you are a great
general manager don't stop being one
okay Gordon thank you thank you so much
thank you so much I'm proud to be the
general manager of the Kon Hotel give me
a hug come
on all well done seriously you can do
the food and beverage you can handle the
room service easily and my God I mean
you bounc back from the dead let me tell
you literally literally literally make
it yours hold on and do not change that
jacket okay why it suits you you know
that and let your team run your business
okay I think this experience with Gordon
was life-changing for everyone here what
you did to get the team back together I
mean I'm telling you no one could have
done but this place is on the road and
good luck I can't wait to come back it's
one of those experiences you'll never
forget
good job guys sometimes you have to
trust no no no no no tonight on Hotel
Hell I'm trying to breathe life back
into a historic country in yeah [__] the
hotel's arrogant owner Robert Dean II
I've always thought you should live with
nice things if you can afford them
treats the Inn like his personal castle
and treats his loyal staff with disdain
go on then you pump as [__] excuse me
don't talk to me like that but what's
wrong with it is this hotel beyond my
help I'm barely surviving financially
and emotionally I mean I'm going to lose
[Music]
everything
the historic Juniper Hill Inn sits on a
Hilltop above the quaint Village of
Windsor Vermont built in 1902 the
country Mansion boast 28 luxurious
bedrooms and two grand dining rooms it
is filled with original works of art and
antiques all museum quality antiques
dealer Robert Dean II and his boyfriend
Ari Nikki bought the business six years
ago I've always thought that you should
live with nice things if you can afford
them these looks good there I thought
you'd like it the guests that we don't
want here are people who don't have a
lot of money the in may look the part
but despite Robert's dreams of an elite
country estate the hotel is barely
functioning Robert Dean has no hotel or
no restaurant experience the prices may
be a little bit high for locals $350 two
night minimum so that's $700 the lack of
communication is very frustrating where
are you I know the customers see that
every day I need my key too I at this
point I can't even get in my room okay
with bookings at an all-time low the
hotel is in serious financial
trouble but that doesn't stop Robert
from living a Millionaire's dream Robert
believes this place is his
playground and the playground for his
friends he's got to have a lot of
clothes made
by he comps all their meals and rooms
but we never get tips they're having a
hard time paying me because they give
away all of their money and food to
their friends showing off using this as
their private castle with hardly any
paying guess it's no wonder that this
Inn is in the red yes we are losing
money more or less like $200,000 a year
I think that the place is going to be
closed and it's that's very sad Gordon
is going to come into this place and say
this place is [__] if I don't stop
this business from bleeding
money it's
doomed I'd love to own an inn in a
setting like this if you get it right
you'd make an absolute Fortune before I
get to Juniper Hill I want to find out
what the town's folk think of the local
in hello how are you very well and
yourself yeah well you me driving all
morning um how do Juniper hell in you're
going to love it it's beautiful um
reputation it tends to be a little on
the high end for our area okay but I
would love to have a place to go to
locally do they not invite locals up
there I feel um that I'd be interrupting
I feel like I'd be intruding are really
what a shame thank you so much have a
great day welcome to Windor thank you
very much indeed take enjoy your visit
thank
you here we are Juniper Hill in now who
in the hell would bring an RV all the
way up here and not stay in that studing
hotel look at
it my God that's beautiful wow okay
round to the front
door can't believe they haven't clear
the snow for guest to come
[Music]
in
w
you're kidding me it's locked that's not
very
[Music]
welcoming why would you have a big
mansion that guests can't arrive through
the front [__]
door Jesus who wants to enter through
the back door
Mr Ramsay's here I need you to do room
one right
[Music]
away at least this door's open finally
hello there how are you how are you Mr
Ramsey black Gordon please blood I'm
Robert Dean Robert Dean we were you over
there I I was at the front door yes okay
this is actually our entrance and in the
winter because of snow ready we have to
keep that locked cuz otherwise the snow
load comes off and kills people kills
people yeah it can have you killed
anyone
no where's all this stuff
from
um an aftermath of a antiques Fair yeah
this looks like it could be a beautiful
room you can't tell because it's stuck
with so much clutter that's the
reception desk no my God so what is that
that is our bar right now you are
kidding me this is the bar yes with what
that martinis martinis God bless him H
made of pigs Pig Martini well we have
three rescue pbell pigs you have three
pigs here
right what is that for were you born
with this in your mouth yeah don't I
wish honestly actually no that was a
gift from GI so yeah Robert obviously
loves to show off all these expensive
antiques but as a guest I don't feel
comfortable I feel like I'm in a museum
this is the main formal dining room this
big chair here is for for one uh just
kind of we're known as a romantic
destination and uh just out of Interest
has well we would move the table move it
in for me please
yes
wow so you got a sofa on the table we
thought it was kind of nice to have like
a cozy
banket oh well three US presidents have
dined here oh really which ones uh Teddy
Roosevelt Calvin kulage Teddy Roosevelt
dined in here wow I wanted to try to
give him a little bit of sense of the
history at Juniper Hill wow okay so
that's the dining room well we have two
dining rooms God you must be busy with
two dining rooms well I wish we were
busy bloody hell we have spurts of being
incredibly busy right uh where we lack
is all the other times really yeah this
place looks like a Millionaire's Mansion
not a struggling business I've got to
scratch beneath the surface this place
per week uh is turning how much we're
lucky if we're doing you know 15,000 a
month what does it cost to keep the
place open 30 ready
y so you're
losing $200,000 a year
it's been a nightmare we maintained our
room rates thinking that the economy
wouldn't be this long a hall but we've
all experienced those kind of difficult
and myself including but you you
navigate your way out of that recession
unfortunately my partner lost his job we
expected him to have his job for a
little longer he must have gained a
substantial payoff or retirement it's
all been put into this how much over a
million dollars a million dollars into
this already Yes and does he have an
active role in the business he tries to
maintain the accounting and he helps
just about with everything we're in
trouble trouble you'd never guess from
the look of this place it's more like
bucking and palis skid Road do you know
what um Robert honestly I like to go
straight to my room if you would mind
please all right wow this place goes on
it does it's the largest col Revival
Mansion in New England and more
paintings and you're in the Maxwell art
Suite which is the original um okay wow
beautiful
room and uh
uh I mean this is uh this is a beautiful
room but why is that smell I mean
seriously it's it does smell yeah it
smell [__] I mean that is horrific oh my
God it smells like
[Music]
sewage coming up Robert staff turn on
him I'm supposed to tell you the truth
right the truth is all I want to know
I'm telling you exactly how I feel and
how the people that I work with feel the
entire staff is ready to walk out you
can talk to him he's your [__] Chef
I'm beyond angry I'm beyond pissed off
and I have to step in how dare you you
still haven't got it get your head out
of your ass and start getting a little
[__] real excuse me go on then you
pump as
[Music]
[__] I'm at Vermont Juniper Hillin and
I've just met its owner Robert Dean II
who's filled his hotel with expensive
art and antiques were you born with this
in your mouth but he can't fill his
rooms and his business is struggling
you're losing $200,000 a year here it's
been a nightmare and no wonder because
although the room he's put me in looks
nice beautiful room it has one major
drawback why is that smell it smells
like raw sewage we had a plumbing issue
and it's like someone's shot under the
bed and um how much this room goes for
$350 a night
$350 a night for room that smells of
[__] well you kidding me we haven't
rented it though bloody hell it's been
out of use for um four months four
months yeah oh come on it has been this
is crazy it is crazy it doesn't make
sense I've got to get out of here it
things sh is there another room yes I
have room too bloody how I didn't
realize $350 to be caked in
[__] wow it's gorgeous and this one
doesn't smell like crap I'm going to
quickly um unpack and then I would um I
would like to have a um a quick bite of
lunch okay I'll I'll notify the what
time is the restaurant closed for lunch
I know we actually don't serve lunch
normally but we're happy to prepare you
something is that a joke we we serve
stop stop stop stop stop you don't
actually serve lunch no the restaurant's
closed for lunch yes if someone requests
lunch we'll make lunch for them but
could you uh prepare lunch for me uh yes
I can I'll tell the chef please okay uh
thank you
yes not open for lunch Gordon is going
to want lunch huh Gordon wants
lunch what am I supposed to do with that
information that a welcome breath of
fresh air on the back of that disgusting
smell of crap in that room I can't
believe it and the rooms are gorgeous
and yet how could you have a room that
has been smelling for months that bad
and then he sticks me in it what a
muppet despite the Hideous smell in that
first guest
room I've still worked up quite an
appetite hello Hi how are you Barbara
Barbara how glamorous are you how nice
it to see you I have a mad crush on good
as he knows I'm a cougar how old are you
now don't old last week I turned 70
you're kidding me you look a million
doll you made my year
70 watch out Joan Collins I'm telling
you now bloody
how Baba what's wrong with this place
well in a nutshell don't get any people
M like pulling teeth to get my paycheck
you don't get paid it takes forever to
get my paycheck and when I do it's
usually something's left out but hold on
a minute you you don't get paid and when
you do not not on time we supposed to
get paid every two weeks so what do you
earn a fortnite I made 6,000 this year
$6,000 a year that's ridiculous you know
you got to have the money flowing and
it's almost come to a stand still at
this point my last paycheck was
$48 unbelievable robers obviously got
enough money to fill the guest rooms
with Fine Art and antique
furniture but he doesn't pay his staff
um I'm starving what would you recommend
crab cakes with a little salad so this
is the dinner menu okay cuz we're not
open for lunch right and the lamb sounds
great as well you want the lamb yeah all
right darling is this a uh prefix menu
or yeah cuz there's no prices on here
what sort of restaurant doesn't have
prices on the menu It's like a club for
millionaires where if you have to ask
you can't afford it I've got a
supplement of $15 from the lamb how much
is enough charge for the lamb is Robert
[Music]
nearby how much is it for three quarters
$59 $59 so if we had the lamb it would
be 74 people are horrified at the price
of the food this is why a lot of people
think that Juniper Hill is snobbish when
we typically take a reservation we will
tell people it's a three course meal
that's for the residents I'm talking
about a local coming in here we're
reservation only though so nobody walks
in we don't have walk how can you expect
to appeal to the locals um we haven't
identified the appropriate people to
come here or hold on what you mean
appropriate people hold on people who
can afford $59 for three courses
appropriate people what a snob where
does he think he is the rits and where's
your table which one's your table uh
well most of the time I eat in our RV
our motor coach say that again oh we
have a motor coach to the side Christ
and where did it come from is it yours
you rent it yeah it's ours we I mean we
owe on it but we bought it and we bought
bought it yeah how much was that over
$100,000 A1
$1,000 you're 3 years away from 50 you
should not be living in an
RV we don't live in um an RV um it is a
motor coach which is the higher end
version of an RV it is that
psychological break for us and it gives
me a place to relax and kind of unwind I
actually love it I could live there the
rest of my life to be honest with you
it's quiet it's clean I suppose if this
place doesn't get fixed then you might
be in there fulltime
[Music]
yeah
I've just sat down for lunch at the
Juniper H and already I found out the
staff aren't paid on time like pulling
teeth to get my paycheck and the owners
live in a camper
outside how much was that over $100,000
this place is baffling I hope the food
makes more
sense excellent
wow where are the crab cakes oh that's
in there underneath there are they mini
crab cakes are we uh the chef has
decided that those are the size that he
needs to serve mhm
I mean that tastes Dreadful that thing
tastes sort of Washi and soapy at $20
for that he's as cheap with his crab
cakes as he is with his
staff now for the Lamb with Robert's
ridiculous $15 extra
charge it's um a rack of lamb incrusted
in macadamia nuts uh fresh herbs and a
little bit of Dijon mustard it's served
with a honey vinegar reduction it's not
even cooked properly rested and take
that
off I always get nervous when you see
white fat like that on the side of the
[Music]
chop is it do your liking I mean it's
pretty raw in the center you like the
flavor of it though the honey
G no way too
sweet
m i I'm I'm not satisfied with uh the
quality of the foods coming out of the
kitchen I believe our Chef has a
learning curve to be where he needs to
be thank
you we just lost our other Chef right
why did the chef
leave I'm supposed to tell you the truth
right the truth is all I want to know
why did the chef leave well her
paycheck she put all everything on her
uh charge cards and and she just figured
she wasn't paid back for what she the
chef bought produce on her CR C did she
did everything she was the best chef
ever prob that's
Dreadful I'm starving um the peanut
butter chocolate decadence I could do
with some of that pick me up please
thank you God a chef that left because
you had to buy produce on her own credit
card I mean this guy's priorities are
upside down bit like this
Inn hey are you ready this he said he
doesn't care for the sweetness there's
fat around it he didn't care for the
flavor of the honey
[Music]
gar
wow thank you very much did you cut it
in half cuz it looks like someone's
taking it and where's the other half
gone uh it goes to the another person
who ERS I know I want my other
half
[Music]
$74 this place is
insane listen half my dessert is missing
if you think I'm spending
$74 for a dessert that is half
[Music]
CAU it's actually quite nice there is
hope I'm sorry I'm going to say that
that is not a dessert that he made
Barbara made it no somebody else makes
desserts it's ordered like store bought
like through one of our purveyors what
where's the chef he's in the kitchen can
you get him out please yes
what how you doing Chef Julian in my
opinion is not living up to his
potential as a chef he will try to cut
corners and I think Gordon needs to know
these things I've just spent $74 for
three plates of absolute dire dated [__]
food crab cakes yes sir you can't put
two little half testicle sized [__]
crab cakes that came from a can there's
bigger [__] cakes chef at a [__]
canopy party my lamb was cold in the
middle the fat was white it was almost
like a mouth full of sugar the best
tasting dish for me was the [__]
chocolate peanut thing that I got served
half a portion that's not even made
[__] in house
what is this there's no Synergy here
there is honestly a lack of
communication often sometimes when I'm
in the middle of doing breakfast service
for the 10 people that we randomly get I
get five texts from him asking me a
question so why are you texting him if
you have a question you should maybe
leave the RV and come out and talk to us
show me those text are you nitpicking
are you trying to control him are you no
I'm trying to make sure I I'm I haven't
been sleeping very well to be honest
with you and uh I've had I've been
beaten down I'll take responsibility for
everything that happens in the kitchen
you don't own the place you own it yet
he's acting more
responsible what do you earn a week if
you don't mind me asking $11,000 before
taxes
400 Jesus Christ almighty $400 a week to
be the head chef in a luxury hotel
that's insane I mean you're barely
surviving I'm I'm I don't know that I'm
even barely surviving if you're not
happy with your work environment you
should leave are you taking the piss or
is it is just an abuse for you what are
you doing to these people this are their
livelihoods this is your
responsibility Rob's World and you're in
an RV 100
Grand everybody is disgusted that you
live in that thing they really are
because it costs so much money and they
can't get their paycheck on
time well that is not the that is not
part of the issue we are surrounded by
wealth and reminded of poverty at the
same time because of that our V it's a
symbol to me that RV is a symbol and
it's a symbol that you separating
yourself from everybody else I'd be very
careful about coming down on me too
hard I'm telling you exactly how I feel
and how the people that I work with feel
let me tell you how I feel when you're
in your [__] kitchen all day long and
you're on the goddamn internet instead
of actually trying to perfect a menu and
get a menu how long did I ask for you to
make a menu of your own and if I'm on
the computer usually is I'm trying to
research menus research ingredients give
me a break I've given you plenty of
breaks I work very long days and I
haven't been paid in 3 weeks there's
only been one paycheck that I got on
time almost the entire staff is ready to
walk out because they are tired of not
getting paid anything to
[Music]
say no we we do things oh
please it's my first day at Vermont's
Juniper Hill in and the battle between
the chef and the owner I'd be very
careful about coming down on me too hard
has turned what should be a Charming
country in into a war zone I'm telling
you exactly how I feel I work very long
days and I haven't been paid in 3 weeks
there's only been one paycheck that I
got on time almost the entire staff is
ready to walk out because they are tired
of not getting paid anything to
say no we're tired and half the team is
broke I'm beyond angry I'm beyond pissed
off
oh I just got a new [__] ripped to me
Gordon says that I live in a fantasy
world and that uh I live in a million
doll RV while our our our employees
can't pay their bills and all of this
kind of stuff cuz we don't pay them on
time and they're all complaining that
they haven't gotten their paychecks this
time either oh they haven't and he said
that everything is all about me I can't
believe what a mess this place is I've
got to get off this hill for a bit there
someone I need to
see hello is that ligher it's Gordon
Ramsey I've got some questions about
Robert and Juniper Hill would you mind
if a pop over for 5 minutes
please great I'll see you then thanks
[Music]
later I think the old Chef that quit
will be able to give me some insight
into what's wrong with juniper
Hill hello are you good to see you good
to see you come on
in give me a little insight to what it
was like actually working there I have
to say it was very interesting 5 years
uh things were going very very well and
then all of a sudden 2 years into it
they stop answering the
phone Robert I think thought he was too
important to answer the phone or he was
too busy doing other things so
preoccupied and distracted in very very
preoccupied and distracted and not
focused at all on maintaining his own
business wow I was getting cut out of a
living when they did all this stuff I
used to earn $40 $50,000 in one
restaurant and now I'm down to earning
uh 15 were you paid on time um not very
often wow um did you ever use your own
money to buy things all the time and
then I would have to demand to be paid
back or we W going to open for dinner
it's insane Barbara has been shorted
checks a lot she's barely earing $100 a
week and yeah and he won't pair and then
if he had a private party with all his
friends he didn't tip them you okay
kidding me no that's just disgusting I
mean that's where I I don't that you
can't do that no you just can't treat
people like that now he's a confirmed
snob and he thinks he's above the town
he thinks he's
Untouchable I'm here to make this place
work and the first thing I'm going to do
is burst his bubble I'd like to be a fly
on that wall but would would you come
back and walk through the doors to have
a look at it at the end of the week and
just come back for dinner no no just
won't go or no I'm not even interested
in getting it I I just fear getting in
one more battle with ar Robert and what
a sh after 5 years yeah do you think
I've got a chance of saving it the
problem he has now is nobody will work
there you know I'm there to get this
place turned around um those staff
deserve a better future they do you know
I I feel terrible for him um listen
thank you you're very welcome um
appreciate your time enjoyed it thanks
like good to see you too byebye
[Music]
byebye how sad is that after 5 years of
her life dedicated to the Juniper Hill
you know she won't even step foot in the
door she doesn't want even see
them the old Chef left because she
couldn't stand it and the current Chef
looks like he's ready to walk too I
wonder if everyone here is feeling the
same frustration Jennifer would you
what's wrong with the place what's wrong
with the place we're lacking uh
paychecks on time paycheck you don't get
paid on time either no we're missing
basic supplies to basic supplies we
don't even have I mean no well purchased
guest checks for us today so that we've
been using scrap pieces of
paper first neighb is I'm Ryan Keith
Ryan Keith what' you do I'm the estate
manager here I do all the maintenance on
the house I've done everything here
though that's why he likes me to spread
out my talents to try and help anybody
wherever they need help how's
morale not
good I personally haven't been paid
since the 6th of January here it is the
1st of February that's nearly a month
and you pay the employees before paying
paying your bills when they've done the
work that's their livelihood I amazed
you're still here working as hard as you
are because staff never needs to be
treated like this let me tell you it's
always as if what you're saying to him
doesn't get through because he sees you
as not an equal he treats me like that
and that really bothers me because I
feel like I've contributed a lot it's
actually pretty degrading this is insane
coming up oh my God I uncover the
shocking extent of Robert's Reckless
spending thousands of dollars worth
hundreds of thousands of dollar Robert's
Dreadful communication skills cause a
meltdown I said where does this chicken
ask him again Tempest flare excuse me I
am the boss and Robert reveals these
True Colors how dare
[Music]
you I'm shocked with what I'm finding at
the Juniper Hill in owner Robert wants
to kill his Chef how long did I ask for
you to make a menu of your own and the
rest of the staff want to kill Robert
how's morale not good estate manager
Ryan has told me about some of the
problems but now he wants to show me if
you want to see the root of the problem
let's go to the basement to the basement
yes please Jesus what's in there
everything oh really it's the majority
of it is personal items no even the
shelves are all lying bloody hell look
at this
place oh my
God look at this stuff stereos wine
racks quilts chair tables copper pans
more chairs over there look at these
Robert Prides himself in having to have
the very best of everything Christ there
enough in here to open three restaurants
is all this stuff still brand new most
of it is brand new littered with
thousands of dollars Robert's got so
much stuff he could furnish a dozen
houses but he doesn't pay his staff it's
crazy where are we going rise yourself
we're going up to the
office you're kidding me oh no come on
come in this is the office this is the
office you kidding me not at all I
wanted you to Jesus Christ scares me
half to death oh my God this is insane
it would only take a day or two to sort
out this hord as heaven but Robert's
left it in chaos no wonder he spends all
day hiding in his
RV this guy has lost the plot this is
disturbing please tell me there's no
more yes there's more this is where the
pigs are
kept at least they look happy hey pigs
who live a life of luxury while everyone
around them them suffers sounds
strangely familiar bloody hell so the
owners live out the pigs live in there's
more so check out the storage units
storage units you are kidding me no oh
my
God this one's all personal items look
at oh Jesus I mean I swear to God it's
like a special edition of
Hoarders I mean honestly
wow I'm in shock you know that and this
one all of this entire storage unit is
full of
chairs oh my
God look at this stuff honestly I mean
they must be packed with thousands of
dollars worth of hundreds of thousands
of dollars how much stuff does one
need fluty
hell I can't believe how much stuff
Robert has bought he must have spent a
fortune I've got to meet Robert's
partner Ari and and find out why he's
financing all
this welcome welcome my name is Ari it's
a pleasure please um my God so how much
money have you put into this business
personally more less over a million
dollars a million dollars and how much
have you seen back
nothing it was all my my uh Seance
packages my income that I when I was
working and then my retirement plans
rapit savings are in artwork and
antiques I have supporting this in with
my my savings clearly this is a
beautiful place but putting your entire
life savings into a sinking ship is
insane and with Robert at the helm
treating your staff so poorly I don't
see things getting any
better Robert is in a fantasy world and
I've been struggling all day to get
through to him this place it's Dreamland
a playground for your boyfriend
Robert your biggest problem is not
Juniper Hill your biggest problem is
[__] Robert
I'm at Vermont's Juniper Hill in and
I've just had a difficult conversation
with Robert's partner Ari who seems
strangely unconcerned about how bad
things really are here how much money
have you put into this business
personally more less over a million
dollars a million dollar and how much
have you seen back
nothing but I've tried to make him see
who's to blame for the problems your
biggest problem is [__]
Robert dinner time is approaching word
have spread about me being at the inn
and the place is bustling good to see
you hello there nice to see you I'm
learning a lot about why the Inn is
struggling by watching Robert and Ari
deal with a new influx of guests anyone
with any restant experience would
stagger the seating of guests but as if
they're just welcoming people to a
dinner party at a private house hello
there how are you Robert and Ari seat
everyone at once there in the corner
make pretend you're back in 1902 it's
meant to be a relaxed evening and and
that's a recipe for disaster for Chef
Julian and the White staff Chef I'm
making a change on 21 write it down
don't tell me just write it down there's
an order are you guys kidding me with
all these orders who said everybody at
once like this best friend we don't know
about
pacing I they said they SL who's writing
the tickets you mean table four table
five some of them have names on them
some of them do not who wrote that
ticket there's not even a table number
in there table four they just got their
lobster where's table 23 they've got I
need one person at a time I need less
talking in the kitchen please table 23
has got put up the window eight people
ask me for something with Julian having
been slammed by the owner's Dreadful
seating Ari isn't helping the strained
atmosphere with an aid art lesson but
then like this this is from 1800 and it
was painted for opera house cuz you know
what it
is what is it come on everybody has to
know what that is it's a hanal going
across the albs with the white elephants
everybody should know
[Laughter]
[Music]
that on the other side of the house
house Robert's also busy giving a
lecture this is one of the original
signs to the house there's a lot of
history here um Teddy Roosevelt actually
was best friends with the man or very
good friend with the man who actually
built the house Maxwell art do you
always get this backed up I mean yes
yeah when I
have po seating Robert has groups of his
friends come in sitting them at once
okay so you're waiting for your starters
then okay well let me uh check on those
for you see how okay yeah
Robert yes this ticket system is
bollocks you know
that handwritten tickets no time on
there no proper dates no
coordination who trains the front of
house team who's in charge of the
restaurant who who is there I would be
the host and then you'll be the host yes
the chef takes over the kitchen this
place is such a mess clearly Robert has
no idea how to run a hotel yeah so me
too I'm trying to straighten out the
damn drinks cuz they lose we lost 30
something drinks oh my
God Robert we lost 30 drinks at least I
often find drinks not written down or
just a lack of follow through and it's a
big problem when we're trying to make
money there's no communication between
the bar and the dining room so people
get served drinks but no one remembers
to charge for them but we're losing big
money no kidding and they're losing
their checks and I'm going crazy trying
to figure out a system they have hardly
any guess and don't charge the ones they
do have no wonder this place is in the
red how does that happen they're
supposed to write the drinks down and
then apply them to a table and a room
and then they go into the
computer the ticket system is bogus and
as I feared seating everyone at once is
already causing problems for the staff
and the
guests it's not very it's burnt with
guests now suffering and the kitchen
falling apart from Robert's ill-managed
seating come on I have to step in um
just just stop
there you have to be [__] kidding me
this Goose liver is burnt to a cinder
stop Jun Julian yes sir come around
buddy I know we're in the [__] and we're
busy food's dying in the
window a f salad I mean
honestly it's like a piece of [__]
beef
jerky where's Ari get me Ari urgently I
mean honestly come on guys hello I
stopped that I just said no what is that
what is that far gr oh that's VRA that
is not forra this is not funny guys no
that is not funny I mean I know we're in
the [__] but does anyone have any
standards here yes well can I see them
can I see something to hold on to cuz
right now I just want to get out of here
I can only be as good as I am with the
tools that I have I'm embarrassed and I
know that I can do better I know the
staff can do better first off no more
[__] tickets in the kitchen give him
10 minutes to catch up okay all right
and Robert is it possible for the first
time put the phone away get your jacket
off and [__] dig deep a little bit
yeah please yeah somebody I'm concerned
that food is in the window and it's just
dying Entre on table six are in the
window entree send them they shouldn't
be sat here how am I supposed to do
everything back here are you with me are
you an owner I'm with you are you an
entrepreneur I keep trying to you know
you can talk to him he's your [__]
Chef well when I try to communicate him
he says yeah yeah yeah no no no no no no
I can't do it no he doesn't [__] find
your balls and tell him you need to talk
I found my balls do I want him to walk
out he's not going to walk out if you
communicate with him talk to him there
well I have been trying to so when he
finishes it send the [__] food
there's always a third dish not ready or
a fourth dish well it must be one or two
minutes behind but unless you [__]
ask how are you supposed to [__] know
I have been asking I said where do this
chicken so ask him
[Music]
again it's the middle of dinner service
at Juniper Hill in and Chef Julian is
drowning under a flood of orders how am
I supposed to do everything back here
owner Robert has finally decided to get
his hands dirty to try and help but is's
utterly incapable of communicating with
his Chef when he finishes it send the
[__] food there's always a third dish
not ready or a fourth dish well it must
be one or 2 minutes behind but unless
you [__] ask how are you supposed to
[__]
know where's the soup go Julian table 23
I just told you one minute ago I need FR
ra where I know I have it right behind
me Julian yes that's what you call
communication it's better communication
that's what you call communication
Robert there's a difference between
interrupting and no communication and
when you [__] put those Entre up
there you make sure they go you've got
to start stepping up and [__]
dictating a little bit cuz this is just
Madness I
agree Jesus Christ it was fuckups from
start to finish and it was a cluster
[__] and Gordon saw that Dreadful with
an owner and Chef so incapable of
communicating with each other it's no
surprise the diners are unhappy and
they're not the only ones while Robert
and Ari are living the dream their staff
are living a nightmare hopefully by
gathering everyone in one room okay I
can get to the root of the problem I've
never seen a hotel an inn in such
disarray there needs to be structure and
there isn't structure it's just like a
scramble it's a
mess there was no order in the kitchen
nobody took responsibility for any one
thing no one has been taught any
standards in any Department really it's
like I'm I'm racing from thing to thing
nobody knows what the other one's doing
there's nobody here that is in control
willing to take charge I did 40 [__]
dinners by myself tonight I could help
you and you've never asked I can cook
the rack of lamb excuse me bragging
about Mak one plate is nothing to brag
about excuse me excuse me I am the boss
you can't call yourself the boss if you
don't [__] pay
them I mean honestly do you think that's
normal Ari do you think that's the way
to look after your team every pay perod
period there was a problem with the
checks every pay period there's a
problem with the checks I don't know
what the problem is but I know it's the
same two people you get to know about it
first or you have to go ask him for your
salary I always ask for it that's
absolutely wrong and the reason is he's
lying no no no he's not lying I would
rather have them wait then write a check
that's going to bounce because I don't
how about telling him it's not going to
be ready rather than having to ask like
some skiy cap in hand please sir may I
get
paid anybody else have to wait yes mhm
how long 5 days more I have to keep
Barbara I had to wait 5 weeks you had to
what I had to wait 5 weeks before I got
a paycheck five weeks guys you come in
and you work your ass off the least
these two guys can do is pay your
[__] salary on time I don't have a
secretary Gordon I'm sorry I'm trying to
communicate with Brides I'm trying to
send out things I have to have peaceful
time in order to do my work are you
always this pathetic I am I am not
pathetic well when are you going to
stand up and start showing some respect
for your team and start growing a pair
to sort of understand the mesh are in I
understand the mess we're in I'm
fighting for the team you dug the
[__] hole yes we did and put them in
it so they're [__] they don't have to
work
here oh my God I me you know the bottom
line is how dare you no they don't have
to work how dare you how [__] dare
you they don't have to work here here oh
my God I I I care you disrespectful
disgusting man they don't have to work
here I don't think you realize how
[__] lucky you are CU if it wasn't
for 1 2 3 4 five six of them you'd be
driving that RV miles away from here
Robert definitely needs a reality check
it's life or death right now and I don't
think he actually realizes what kind of
Jeopardy this place is in it's not all
about you Robert Robert's world Robert's
bubble Robert's dream you're not the
lord of the manner and you're not the
Great Gatsby you're you're Robert it's
only me in here excuse me excuse me go
on then you pump as [__] excuse me don't
talk to me like that but what's wrong
with it I want to know what's wrong with
speak to me like that well I'm telling
you get your head out of your ass and
start getting a little [__] real you
still haven't got it that this place is
sinking start paying a little bit more
attention to the guys on the
ground understand how hard it is out
there there forget your [__] Antique
Road Show and start from the bottom
running this business you're right
there's no structure it's fragmented the
team needs a leader they need a
structure they need a mentor they need
some support and all they get is
nitpicks what kind of motivation is that
all I've heard since I've been here
you're just blaming people well I'm
blaming you for not taking charge get
[__]
real [__]
H next time my Hotel Hell continues
Roberts Miss management spreads like a
virus this time taking down the kitchen
what's the matter with you now do you
want to give me your jacket and I'll do
it for you open up come on you've just
shut down and there's a revelation so
shocking that is dis disgusting I have
to do something I've never done before I
think my time's done here Gordon left I
cannot stand anymore these bloody lies I
just don't seem that I can do it anym I
no I can't do
it